but it's an absolute honor to meet you
can you introduce yourself uh yeah Tim
it's great to be here thanks a lot for
the invitation um I'm a professor at
einthoven University of Technology uh
which is located obviously in einthoven
in the south of the Netherlands together
with my students we work on developing a
toolbox for realizing active influence
agents when I first
read
about uh the FR principal this is about
10 years ago it was mostly about
neuroscience and um and the and and how
variation of free energy was the only
ongoing process so that was uh brilliant
but it was sort of in a way cast as
information processing then a few years
later k started talking about this is
really just the principle of this action
apply to self-organizing systems apply
to information processing that must be
going on in self-organizing systems in
biologic iCal systems in brains but but
but even even all um self organizing
systems more recently this um
interpretation of um a new branch of
physics I think is is has been
developing more strongly and I think
that's really exciting because now it
has a very solid footing it's a new
branch of lran mechanics which is which
is the basic of of physics in general uh
the principle of least action is um
centuries old very rich history uh you
can derive almost everything in physics
from principle of least action so it has
a very very solid footing now and um
it's so important um it will affect not
only
um uh AI but I think engineering and uh
and science everywhere that at some
point in the future I think the freen
principle will be taught in high school
in uh in the Natural Sciences or the
physics
curriculum in the space of physical laws
the principle of least action gives us a
parsimonious explanation for
trajectories of systems both simple and
complex rooted in the calculus of
variations this principle asserts that
the actual path taken by a system is one
where the action integral defined as the
integral of the lran over time is
stationary the lran encapsulating the
difference between kinetic and potential
energy serves as the Cornerstone for
this minimization process at its core
it's an optimization process a theme
resonating deeply within all of the
Sciences in a conceptual leap to
cognitive science Carl friston's free
energy principle mirrors this optimality
this idea that posits that biological
systems in their interaction with a
dynamic and uncertain World navigate by
minimizing free energy which represents
a bound on the surprise incurred by
their sensory States this act of
minimizing a Scala quantity to regulate
and predict environmental exchanges
parallels the principle of least action
Illuminating broader principles that may
underly both physical and living
systems the Elegance of least action
guides our understanding of motion and
change in acknowledging the principles
relevance to friston's free energy
principle we glimpse a unified view of
Nature's economy a suggestion of a
pervasive lawfulness that reaches from
the celestial mechanics of orbiting
planets all the way down to the
intricate dance of neuronal
activity the principle of least action
is sort of an umbrella framework that
says in in nature energy differences of
any kind are
minimized um as fast as possible so when
for for big things that move about in
the world the difference between kinetic
and potential energy are minimized for
charged particles that move about in in
electric and magnetic fields the
difference between electric and magnetic
um energy is minimized if you do that
minimization so if you do that
mathematic
by um finding the minimum of this of
these of this action functional you find
the equations of motion so in the in the
case of electromagnetics you find
Maxwell's equations in the case of
classical mechanics you find Newtons
equations and in the case of the free
energy principle you find update
equations for information processing in
brains and in in in other biological
systems the basically what we do in in
our lab is to implement these equations
of motions for information processing
this is just basian information
processing so like a military ruck sack
it is exactly that right pretty much and
and and walk to work that way because I
have a 20 minute walk it's like a
farmer's walk right but it's fantastic
for everything for your core I if you
just if you walk with like I don't know
like 30 40 PBS on your back to it for 20
minutes I walk with 30 or 40 PBS on my
stomach does that count does that does
that it counts too sh it does count
because I'm sure your legs are a lot
stronger than my legs yeah
probably now as many of you know we've
had Professor friston on the show many
many times now um he is the ultimate
gentleman he he's a huge inspiration to
me and I guess Professor friston more
than anyone else has really inspired BS
research efforts going back about 10
years or so now so if you're saying that
the superorganism is just drawing a mark
of blanket around a particular culture
or um you know Society or population or
Ensemble or and not set ofon specifics I
think you you you made a very clear
point before that you know you cannot
get a joint free free energy Minima um
just by looking at one kind of species
you know it has to be an ecosystem that
necessarily has also sorts even at one
given scale sorts of different kinds of
um phenotypes within it things to eat
things that do the eating things that do
the you know the um the breathing and
the things that you breathe that
scale-free perspective uh and
particularly the separation of um
temporal scales and scales that
distinguish between an individual and
the population or the ensemble in which
that individual finds herself um is
absolutely fundamental and that
certainly could be a attributed um um
sort of mental states of a of a minimal
or uh basic sentience sort this is a
really interesting Vision where
everything from Individual cells to
entire vast cultural systems are
underpinned by the same fundamental
rules friston paints a picture of an
interconnected hierarchy where each
layer whether it's an organ a body or an
entire Society is subject to the
Relentless discipline of the free energy
principle each encapsulated by the
concept of a markof blanket so verses
invited me to their Swanky offsite a few
weeks ago uh they're the main company
implementing active inference
commercially and KL friston is their
Chief scientific officer and this is
kappen Peterson their Chief Innovation
officer yeah yeah exactly that that's
where you point your attention to and
it's just also a beautiful model because
it really decreases amount of energy you
need in order order to just observe and
to sense right because right now these
systems we have today they're taking all
this data in it's not sparse right it's
just it's too much data to be able to
really uh to manage and to compute and
so to be able to take that and really
just narrow it down to the area that you
really need to focus on just like our
eyes do right to create that kind of
model will reduce the energy consumption
that these models
[Music]
need variational energy often discussed
in the context of the free energy
principle
is a mathematical concept arising from
probability Theory and it's at the core
of how scientists believe our brains
deal with an uncertain world now imagine
you're in a bustling Street Market
there's a frenzy of sights and smells
and sounds your brain is being bombarded
with sensory information now to make
sense of this chaos your brain is
constantly making educated guesses about
what's going on around you it might
deduce a sizzling sound as sausages
cooking or the aroma of coffee as a
barista does their work now these
predictions are a bit like little bets
that your brain places and when sensory
data matches these predictions your
brain gets to say ah I Told You
So when the predictions don't match your
brain needs to pay up figuratively
speaking it's like a debt so variational
energy represents the difference between
what your brain predicts and what
actually happens when this variational
energy is high it means that there's a
significant mismatch your brain is
surprised and it doesn't like surprises
now to minimize this surprise which
scientists quantifiably call prediction
errors how original your brain adjusts
its internal models of the world now it
involves tweaking and refining all of
those little guesses to get a better
handle on the barrage of sensory
information and this process is akin to
a sculptor chiseling away on a block of
marble with every single strike the
unnecessary bits fall off and the
intended figure slowly materializes into
existence now similarly your brain is
sculpting a model of the world where
minimizing the variational energy chisel
away the misinformation between
predictions and reality revealing a
clearer picture of the world now the key
idea is to find a simpler distribution
known as the variational distribution
which is close to the true complex
distribution that we're interested in
and by close I mean that the variational
distribution minimizes a certain
Divergence measure from the true
distribution which in this case is the
KO Divergence in essence these methods
transform a difficult problem into a
more manageable one by finding the best
approximation within a specific family
of
distributions now while Exact Solutions
are often unattainable variational
methods grant us the next best thing an
approximation that lets us make
structured inferences about the state of
the world or the underlying process
being
studied I I I think the the last word on
the relationship between information and
uh um and and physics hasn't hasn't been
hasn't been said yet right but if I look
at the the the variation of free energy
and it allows a decomposition in what's
called a complexity term minus accuracy
term the complexity
term uh measures how much the your
beliefs are moving so you can interpret
this as a as a kinetic energy of
information processing the accuracy term
tells you something about how much do I
know about about something else this is
what this is the potential energy so
there even uh also for the so for the
free energy principle you can you can
kind of see this uh that it's trying to
minimize the difference between energies
if you if you will yes yes but maybe
just to linger on this a tiny bit what
do you think is the relationship between
entropy and information in information
Theory it's it's it's you you you can
interpret it as a generalization of the
variance of a gaan distribution there
are many other distributions they don't
have to have one Peak but they can have
multiple picks and if you want to
express in one value High how WID spread
how spread is this function is this
distribution then entropy is uh is a is
your measure now there are much better
derivations for it but this is a way of
how it measures the spread of a
probability distribution then of course
there's a a whole physical
interpretation about that it's the it's
the uncertainty that you have about a
micro
States um in a in a physical system when
you can only measure measure micro
States
um there is an interpretation that I
like very much in uh information
processing and this is by Ariel
CA and he posed the question so let's
say I have a probability distrib ution
over a set of variables and we know that
the only rules for manipulating these
probability distributions are some
product rules that's what probability
theory is about but now I inject
information I want to inject information
get EXT information from the site into
that distribution how should I process
that if that new information is uh an
observation you can use a likelihood fun
function and use base rule but sometimes
new information is not an
observation uh sometimes it's just a
constraint on the probabil on on the
probabilities I want to be in my the
temperature of my body must be around
36° Centigrade but not exactly so there
is a probability distribution this is
new information I want to incorporate
that and he shows or actually it goes
back to an article in 1980 by short and
Johnson that the proper way to update
your probability distribution with new
information is to incorporate the
information and then choose the maximum
entropy distribution the so the the most
uninformative
distribution while accepting the the the
new constraints this is the same thing
as saying we're going to you do
variational free energy minimization
subject to the constraints in in other
words variational free energy
minimization is really the optimal way
of processing
information and so in that sense we're
are we're doing the right thing
right so we're doing probabilistic
inference we have these probabalistic
graphical models and the problem is
these normalized uh distributions that
we want to compute are intractable the
domain is exponentially large so how do
we do this well you probably know about
Mark of chain Monte Carlo especially if
you've watched the introduction to our
Benjo show now that's a great way of
getting an optimal solution to modeling
these normalized distributions but
unfortunately it can take exponential
time to run right we don't have all the
time in the world so another thing that
we can do is a family of methods called
variational um inference now essentially
the idea is that you cast inference as
an optimization problem the first thing
you do is you create a low resolution
approximation
of the distribution that you want to
match and then you have an optimization
problem that kind of tweaks the knobs
and the levers on that distribution
until it fits as closely as possible to
the distribution you want to
match this is Dan Mapes the president
and co-founder of verses yeah it seems
to be a uh it seems that intelligence
really wants to uh expand itself into
the world I mean we're we're the the
latest form of but you know from all the
brains that have been on the planet for
the last 200 300 400 500 million years
right since the Cambrian explosion if
you like but uh now it's kind of just
spreading on out into synthetic minds
and uh wow that giv infinite possibility
I don't think humans are going to do
real well living on mars or other
planets but uh if we have uh sentient
robots there and uh we can see through
their eyes and things like that that'll
be a lot of fun fun I was talking to
Kapp before and he and he was telling me
how you how you taught them that the
20-year-old Gabe um and Capen to think
big to think globally and now he's
thinking as far as
M there's a real engineering challenge
implementing the free energy principle
so um when we speak with friston we talk
about this beautiful principle that is
quite abstract and can be applied at
many scales and when we talk about the
engineering reality we're actually
building these models that do
variational inference and we have this
explosion of computational complexity
and we have to do a whole bunch of hand
crafting and it's not quite as um you
know some of the Purity kind of melts
away I guess what are the biggest
problems that that you're trying to
overcome so far the discussion has
mostly
been how can you get away with not doing
cost functions how can can you get away
with not doing control right how can you
get away with just doing prediction and
updating uh uh and and and error
correction um it never has been so far
about how to implement it so let's say I
want to build an active influence agent
for for autonomous driving for a car and
uh so my car is driving on the road and
I see another car is is coming at me so
I need to avoid that car um that means I
have to apply a Calon filter to that to
to the path of that car and also a calel
filter to well the path of my own car
and that means that if these Calon
filters consume 5 Watts I am U I have to
spend 10 watts so as I get closer to
that car I see there certainly a cyclist
on the road I need to avoid that cyclist
as well and I have a look in my rear
view mirror and I see there's another
car homing in at me I need to also keep
track of that car because I cannot break
very hard now now I have to uh run four
Calon filters and with a budget of 10
watts I only have two and a half Watts
for each Calon filter so I have to keep
Shifting the power budget to each Calon
filter and you can imagine in a world
that keeps changing I have to actually
have available Calon filters that run on
one Watt and on 1.1 watts and 1.2 watts
and so forth for a whole range of of of
uh latencies as as well I cannot program
all of that in my um in my system and
that means I have to have a different
programming strategy I just I have to
have a reactive programming strategy I
just have to let it happen I must be
able to apply two watts to my common
filter and one watt if I apply one watt
it won't be as accurate but I still want
a Calon filter I still want it to to run
and that's one of the difficulties of
implementing uh reinforcement learning
with active inference
um I think that active INF actually has
a chance of doing of of of being
implemented in this way so in the way of
these fluctuating uh uh resources and I
think it's much harder to do that for
for uh let's say competitors of active
inflence leg reinforcement learning this
is Jason Fox the chief technology
officer at versus no no you're right I
we're we're as Engineers just like in
general I think you're used to
deterministic systems right and you know
uh machine learning AI introduces a lot
of non- determinist outputs that you
have to learn how to deal with and adapt
to and specifically large language
models are probably the one of the most
non-deterministic machines that I've
ever had to interface with this is ridy
Jane piter a researcher at Oxford
University working on active inference
oh gosh how does that work if I had the
answer to that we wouldn't be over here
with a team of researchers I wish I had
the answer to that um no we're still
working on that we're still developing
it we're trying to scale it up in a very
manageable practical manner that is
still very very principled I think that
is
just Carl does an excellent job of just
keeping us grounded to make sure that
everything is done in a principled
manner so then we really get the
emergent properties from the
propositions of the model um and in that
hope I'm hoping we can form some some
form of a
a digital version of intelligence as
captured by our reality of intelligence
that exists all around us not like
non-human intelligence as well right you
were working in a similar industry to to
me my startup x-ray um you were doing
signal processing for hearing aids and
you were just speaking before we hit the
record button about this agential view
so active inference in a sense is about
seeing the world and or modeling the
world with agents and you are saying how
you could model a hearing aid as being
an agent actually I'm still working on
on on hearing aids oh sorry um in in in
my research projects and I'm also still
uh affiliated with a hearing aid company
for a day per week um yeah so a hearing
aid is a is well we know what a hearing
aid is it's a it's a small device that
processes an audio signal it's designed
by a hearing aid manufacturer by
Engineers on their desks and um it has
an algorithm with lots of parameters you
go as a client to a
dispenser the
dispenser plugs in good values for your
parameters and you very happy and then
you leave everything is fine until a few
weeks later when you are at a restaurant
and you cannot understand your
conversation partner there's nothing you
can do the designers of this algorithm
they're not there the the the the the
the engineer and the audiologist are not
with you
so you have a problem um what I would
like to do is to make the hearing aid
itself a self-organizing agent that is
responsible for keeping the patient in a
satisfactory state with respect to the
Acoustics right meaning that if the uh
the the hearing aid now is an agent that
tries to estimate what is the state of
the the client and if it's not happy it
tries to explore actions by setting
parameter values to different values um
uh so explore actions so as to make the
patient happy again to actions by by by
changing parameters in a hearing it
algorithm will of course change the
processing and will change the sound
signal that uh client will hear um so
that is that would mean that the
designer who is responsible for
Designing the hearing aid now moves from
people that are professionals at their
desks to the hearing a itself under incu
circumstances and I think it has a
mendous Advantage if you can solve
problems um with your hearing aid in the
field as they occur yeah and I think
this is such an an instructive example
because we speak about natural
intelligence so we're moving away from
something which is statically programmed
and at x-ray we see this all the time so
different handsets do different types of
audio processing and I have to look at
the spectrogram and you know some of
them do voice isolation some of them do
Dynamics processing and and they're
making assumptions about what works best
in all situations or or even sometimes
they do some personalization it's still
just really old school right what we
need is an agent that can make
Intelligent Decisions based on the
environment that they're currently in
but it leads to the question though of I
guess alignment because we're talking
now about growing an AI rather than
designing an AI and you know we we we
now need to gently pressure it to do the
right thing in the right situation how
would we do
that okay uh this is uh this is a a
problem we we actually get I think to
the difference between reinforcement
learning and active inference and there
I think there's first there is a big
difference in philosophy right in in in
in reinforcement learning comes from
psychology um then made made
quantitative by people like Andrew Barto
and Rich Satan and it's it's beautiful
Theory but um in active inference we say
the entire process is variational free
energy minimization so there is
a there is a there is a a conceptual big
difference um
in reinforcement learning the idea is
there are valuable states in the in the
future um a patient that's Happy is a
valuable States so I want to measure
that by having a value function over
those States and the idea is for the
hearing aid now to take actions to
fulfill or to maximize the expected
value um so that's fine if the world
doesn't change because that value
function is a proxy is a reflection of
your problem statement maximizing that
value function is your solution proposal
so where's the problem well it's
contained in that value function now if
the world changes or if a situation
occurs that you didn't test for that you
didn't like going into a restaurant and
the cluttering of utensils is is very
annoying you didn't test for that so
there's a new
situation then reinforcement learning
cannot deal with that because it cannot
adapt the problem statement the value
function so in active inference the
function is a variational free
energy the variational free energy
decomposes into two
terms one is minus the logarithm of the
probability of the data it's it scores
based in evidence it's scores how well
does the model represent the world how
well does my model predict the world
it's your problem representation
costs plus a so-called Kolb livel
Divergence
between the variational posterior and
the uh the basian posterior you can
think of that as your solution
costs in active inference everything the
entire process is inference so the
solution is obtained by
inference and so now you have a cost
function that underneath has problem
costs Plus Solution costs if the world
changes in active inference
the model the problem cost will go up
and free energy minimization over the
structure of the model will happen if if
that's built in your uh if you have a
toolbox for that and so then your your
model will keep
following uh uh the world and in that
way uh uh do a lot better job on the
alignment problem because it can follow
the world could we just um clarify for
the audience cuz as as you say
reinforcement learning we have this
concept of a value function or an
advantage function and we have a um a
reward and the reward is handcrafted
it's usually quite brittle and hacky but
it but it's domain specific and it's
intelligible you know that there's going
to be alignment problems of course but
in the free energy principle it's far
more principled than that so we're just
minimizing basian surprise essentially
and the mations of that you were just
talking about there's this KO Divergence
which is like you know how much should
we penalize based on the difference
between these probability distributions
but I guess I'm saying that that's
Fidelity it's not really a pressure to
do a particular thing and then on the
top we could move towards goal-based
learning and we can kind of say okay
well I'm now going to apply specific
pressures to meet certain goals so could
you contrast that with value based
learning and just yeah yeah
um so in in the frey or in an active
inflence process all that happens is you
have a a Model A generative model of the
world that model makes predictions of
sensory
observations that is matched by well by
the sensory observations you have
predictions errors and these prediction
errors are processed and
um there is a little twist namely that
um we are allowed to set constrains on
the that generative model which which
makes that generative model not just a
model of the world as it is but more of
a model of as we want the world to be in
the future so when we roll out the this
biased generative model we um we're
going to have a representation of where
we want states to be in the case of a
hearing aid one of the states could be
this the the the estimated satisfaction
level of the patient I could clamp that
to satisfactory values the values that
we say okay this this represents a
satisfied patient
um so now if if I do now variation of
fre enery minimization
then all the actions um will be inferred
both explorative and exploitative to
fulfill that future state to fulfill the
the promise that the the patient is
going to be happy okay on on that though
there are there's ambiguous trajectories
so if if a if a goal is a future State
you can get there in many different
ways sometimes you might not be enacting
it you might be imagining it and the
representation might be quite brittle uh
because it depends on on the underlying
Factor model structure you know your
your basian model and so on so does does
that introduce any form of brittleness
or or problems for from an engineering
point of
view yeah I mean the let's say the path
that will be taken is is is is is an a
resource um conserving path actions will
be taken to elicit information to
resolve the uncertainty so so it's data
preserving we want smart data it's also
power conserving because this complexity
term in the free energy
sort of is is the movement of the
beliefs and it it relates to um how much
power if if I move my beliefs I need to
consume power so so how much power needs
is to be
consumed um so the path that will be
taken is the yeah the the the the path
that consumes the least amount of
resources you will always have in theal
principle a tradeoff between accuracy
the goal that you want to achieve and
and how much resources you will
consume in active inference you will
never build a perfect model you will
build a just good enough problem
representation and just good enough
solution for that problem it doesn't
help you to have a fantastic problem
representation and not being able to do
inference in that model M it doesn't
help you to have a very poor problem
representation and do perfect in in that
model because then you solve the wrong
problem so active
inference solves basically will give you
a just good enough solution for minimal
resources that's the path that we be
taken this is Steven Swanson the chief
Administration officer at versus uh well
there's this thing called Black Swan
phenomenon where there three criteria
one is uh it's it's an has a huge impact
uh number two it couldn't have been
predicted but number three in hindsight
it was obvious and so you know
microwave would be probably an example
Computing you know Vehicles you know any
number of of really big impactful uh
Technologies or inventions in hindsight
they're kind of of course you know
someone should would could have invented
that and in this case I think the
Notions of interoperability and
governance and agent-based systems it
will be in hindsight obvious um I think
there's an audacity that underlies it
where because the wicked problem in
Computing is that in the very beginning
of digitalization and Computing every
company every appware app software
developer took these ingredients took
these recipes these um software code and
and data structures and kind of
reinvented the wheel on their own and so
you end up with this Tower of Babel
where everyone's got their own you know
unique uh combination of those
ingredients and the interoperability and
the connections between them is very
fragile and delicate and very bespoke to
get him to work and it's kind of janky
and so this idea of like what if we
started from not scratch but we started
from a universal Baseline that not
everyone has to drop what they're doing
and adopt but build connectors to it so
that there is a bit of a Rosetta Stone
not just from a communication standpoint
but from a data structure standpoint the
idea is simple and again I think obvious
in hindsight but kind of profound in its
imp implications yeah and I don't I mean
I don't know that correspondence I don't
know about quantum mechanics and not
many do you know we we interviewed
Steven Wolfram and he's got this book
out about the second law of um yeah
thermodynamics and of course he thinks
it's all the the ruad which is
interesting but and and and you know um
Quantum stuff emerges from that but I
guess what struck me is just how um how
many fundamental things like that are
still uh theorized by physicist yeah
whereas if it's a camera like that then
then it's like oh you know I'm I'm on
camera so there's so much I want to say
but I want to save it I want to save it
for record all right okay I don't want
to lose any uh don't want to lose any
potential material it was uh I was
really I really enjoyed your
presentation that you recorded for this
active infant Institute uh oh thank you
appreciate that because that that is
kind of what we're doing um I mean we're
building a toolbox for free Eng
minimization and I don't we don't follow
the actor model but but from what I read
about it after you talked about it it's
it's it's quite similar right our
factors are autonomous systems that just
decide for themselves when to Fire and
what to Fire and uh and there's no
guiding umbrella algorithm really it's
just a reactive system yeah what's
what's interesting about
um uh the Octor model and Tim and I and
and a guy who works with us at x-ray we
we talked about this quite a bit over
the last few months is um because of the
kind of current state really of of
programming languages uh it turns out
that that the most usage I've gotten out
of the actor model is really applying
its
principles or subsets of its principles
to you know throughout the code it's
kind of like okay I go and write a class
maybe I'm writing a function for example
and I'll use Factor model principles
when I design that that function so for
example you know early on we we settled
on um the fact that the best way for us
to communicate between threads is
through concurrent cues like you just
have these these cues and you pass
information right and if you do it that
way if you if you're pretty strict about
having all communication essentially
being through these message you know
pipelines it saves you so much headaches
with trying to
debug uh you know multi-threading
problems like essentially you just you
know you've isolated the computer you
don't have shared state where they're
sitting there overwriting each other um
right so principles like that are so
useful it's the ultimate divide and
conquer strategy right um yeah I mean
Bert thank you so much for for uh
joining us today I'm really looking
forward to our
conversation yeah so am I I mean thanks
so much for inviting me really a
pleasure you know one um one reason I'm
really looking forward to it and it's
something you said in the in the email
you sent over to us you said hey look
guys you know um um I'm not a
philosopher I'm an engineer right and
and I appreciate that so much because
while Tim and I do the show which does
oftentimes Meander off into into
philosophy you know it's it's not our
day job our our day job is we're
Engineers we're software engineers and
so our bread and butter and what we do
for way more hours than we probably
should you know almost every day of the
week is is engineering and I mean you
would agree with that right Tim
absolutely yeah yeah and what's what
what I find interesting about
engineering is because it's not an
open-ended research effort you know
you're trying to solve problems on
deadlines right it's like you got to get
this solved in six months months or 1
month or 6 days right and and that that
Crucible really forces you to find
solutions to problems and you don't care
whether they're theoretically Pure or
you know anything like that you just
you're looking for things that that work
and what I found my personal experience
has been that when I was put in that
Crucible it forced me to sometimes
without even me knowing that these were
paradigms even existed until later to
discover among other things basian
methods um the relational data model the
actor model of compute and I think for
some people active inference you know
falls into the same category of things
has that been your experience too that
just the The Crucible of needing to
solve difficult real world problems is
what's pushed you into these
domains yeah absolutely um yeah in um in
in my case I mean by the way the the
active influence Community is is is
still so small that I think almost
everybody who is doing research or
development in active inference has an
interesting story where they came from
um and in my case I was I was just a
researcher in in the hearing aid field I
was doing Digital Signal processing for
hearing aids and uh the the issue with
digital with hearing aids is that the
designers of the hearing aids are namely
the engineer and the um audiologist they
aren't there when the problem occurs in
the field with a hearing it patient who
cannot understand her conversation
partner or whatever the problem is uh
cluttering
utensils and so um I was just browsing
the internet during Christmas reading
random papers and I happened to read and
this was uh I still remember
2013 uh with Christmas I was I happened
to read a paper a Rough Guide to the
brain by Carl friston that I never heard
of car friston but it resonated with me
because it was talking about based
inference variational basan inference
and I had been interested in that kind
of stuff and it hit upon me that um
because of the wording in that paper
that um hey if we would use this theory
that I didn't understand but perhaps we
could use this Theory to make the
hearing a itself be responsible for its
success and for uh taking control uh in
the field when problems occur in how to
solve it let the hearing aid take the uh
the initiative to design the trials and
and that kind of thing so um yeah that
uh and and yeah I
think this this idea of because there is
a
pressure um to solve things that um as
an engineer you read papers with a
certain purpose right I I I I read I
read papers then sort of browsing not no
that that but always being alert that it
might be interesting for solving the
problems that I have right um I also
find that um I mean I've I've been for a
very long time more than 20 years
uh purely in industry and then only very
recently a few years ago I went to
Academia that um the main difference is
in Academia
um it's it's almost enough if a problem
is
interesting and in in in Industry it
must be interesting if you're a
researcher you don't want to work on on
not interesting problems but it must
also be important right so so you have
to have that second Criterion of that it
has to be important and uh so that's
that's Al always in the back of my mind
when I when I read a paper right I mean
what's the relevance of it aside from
whether it's interesting or not how how
can we use
it yeah and I almost I almost find it's
it's almost a magical moment when you
know you're an engineer you're trying to
solve some problem you start to you
start to arrive at a solution and maybe
you've got a a partial bit of solution
and then you happen to chance upon a
paper that introduces you to an entire
set of Concepts and studies that you
didn't even know the name of like for
example the actor model you're like oh
my God this is great there's a whole
bunch of people that have worked on this
problem and have tried to solve it and
Tim I know you and I had a very similar
experience with with the actor model and
you you know you even wrote some
libraries you know years ago Microsoft
like tell me about what drove you to to
that framework and data flow and what it
felt like when you figured out this was
a thing I mean when when I was at
Microsoft we uh we were doing lots of
deep learning projects and uh it was a
different deep learning project almost
on a month-by-month basis but um yeah it
we needed a streaming architecture so we
came at it from from the point of view
of streaming and we were using Python
and I think there was a library called
pipe by Julian palard if I remember his
name correctly which allowed you to do
something not too dissimilar to uh link
you know integrated language query and C
and we essentially just overloaded that
so that you could pass around streams of
um python dictionaries which represented
mini batches and deep learning training
and yeah we just kind of built this
whole um you know framework around it
but streaming is is an important
component of active Frameworks yeah AB
absolutely I mean yeah I and I mean this
you know it's so funny how this idea of
of message passing between
autonomous you you know actors um agents
things you know in the most General case
whatever you want to say it just this
simple message passing is such a
powerful mechanism right Bert I mean you
know we're going to get into this a bit
more later but I mean you've done you've
done some tremendous work on on just how
much you can get away with with this
simple the simple mechanism of message
passing and we'll talk about it more
later but just just in general isn't it
a bit strange that such a simple
mechanism a marov boundary and messages
going across them comes so much
capability absolutely absolutely and um
so I I think I mean if you have a a
non-trivial model so a model that has a
large number of variables and you need
to do inference in that model you must
factorize you must factorize and you
must say okay I have just these modules
I'm going to have a modular approach but
I must have modules and each module
depends
just on a subset of variables and then
these modules communicate with each
other so in in
probability notation that's just you
have
factors you can draw a graph for Factor
graph just a visualization if you do now
inference in that graph you have message
passing so in practice to me any bigger
model if you really want to do beian
inference you are already doing message
passing you you don't get around it it's
just that
when the problem scales up nothing else
nothing else uh uh will do right um You
you want to take advantage of the
independencies and message passing does
that um um through yeah the distributive
law but uh but but I mean um it does it
in a in a in it's not say in a
transparent way you don't have to do
anything about it and um so yeah I think
message passing is the way to do beas
inference
in almost every any non-standard setting
or or let's say non-al
setting yeah and I think it's worth us
kind of diving in a bit for the the
listeners on you know what what this
fundamental problem is we trying to
solve and and why it's so difficult and
and so my perspective is that you know
it's it's clear really if you study it
much okay if you study probability
Theory much that the basium methods are
the one true you know they're just the
one true
mathematical analysis method you know
for these kind of probabilistic
situations the problem is um when you
try to apply it you get confronted
rather quickly as soon as you get into
any interesting model or a large enough
model with these massive integrals okay
that that you have to perform um and and
you know sometimes are related for
example to marginalization you know
folks out there have heard that um but
basically it's saying you hey look uh
here's how you solve the problem it's
this massive multi-dimensional integral
and that's just not something that we
can do computationally and so you have
to find shortcuts you have to find heris
STS you have to find tools that allow
you to do an approximate you know
solution to this very very difficult
problem efficiently and that's really at
the heart of what you're what you're
talking about
right yes absolutely um just to to as as
a bit of a side remark when you because
you mentioned the term marginalization I
I I read the other day uh something
Michael Jordan wrote I I I mean the
Michael Jordan from Berkeley not the the
basketball player yes yes and uh so he
wrote he said well if you if you build
complex systems there are two very
important uh Concepts one is modularity
and the other is
abstraction and it's exactly those two
concepts that are very nicely captured
in probability Theory
namely modularity by
factorization and abstraction by
marginalization and so this is one of
the reasons why probabilistic reasoning
works so well in complex systems but I
mean and and then there is of
course um you you can even prove go
going back all the way to Richard Cox in
I think 1948 or around the around the
40s that if you want to design a
calculus for dealing with un certainty
and you um you you you you you assume a
few
basic axioma ex aoms like oh if I
believe more in a than in B and I
believe more in B than in C then my
calculus must derive or must infer that
I believe more in a than in C otherwise
it's just not logical with a few of
those assumptions that we all agree
on probability calculus turns out to be
the the the unique calculus for for for
for for for calculating with uncertainty
right it is the it is the natural
extension to to logic to bullyan
logic um the there is a um now in terms
of implementing it you you you talk
about integrals and U
so um in practice in practice the the
the proper ways indeed for energy
minimization
[Music]
um there is something very nice about
message passing that a lot of people
don't realize and that is that I mean in
active inference we just need to
minimize free energy that's the only
thing we need to do but if you go out in
the world if an agent goes out in the
world it's interrupted all the time
because there's new things happening
that were not expected there suddenly if
you're in traffic suddenly is's a car
coming coming from from behind you or
whatever and you have to whatever you
were doing you have to get
interrupted if if you implement freee
energy minimization by message passing
then every time two messages Collide on
the graph you do a little bit of free
energy minimization you carve away a
little bit of free energy and you can do
thousands of messages per per
millisecond in a in in a in a in a in a
reasonable computer and that means that
you can interrupt at any time because if
the only process is free minimization
and we can do free energy free energy
minimization consists of sort of a
nested free energ free energy
minimization by passing messages that
that that only live for a millisecond or
even
shorter then we can scale the amount of
computation we do for our Calon filters
we can run Calon filters on 300 messages
per per millisecond but also Calon
filters on 100 milliseconds and we can
stop a Calon filter short after 50
messages and just read out the state and
oh this is the best we have at this
moment but and that's what we need in um
in when when we have situated in in
agents when we go into the field and I
think so it's no surprise that the the
the brain sort of is well is doing kind
of a reactive messes passing kind of
thing right uh because it need the brain
gets interrupted all the time at least
the processes in the brain get
interrupted all the time
yeah and I I'd like to dive a bit and
and this is a this is a favorite topic
of Tim so I'd like to pull him in in
here too which is really the the
situated you know it's the situated case
right I.E an agent who's not in some
abstracted theoretical pure pure state
but more like it's in a world it's
interacting it's interacting with other
agents with the environment you know
it's almost it's almost necessary that
it has to be able to have this type of
autonomy where it can handle
interruptions it can interrupt the
process itself I mean am I am I spinning
that correctly Tim because I know this
is this is something that you think a
lot about yeah I mean we were speaking
about this a bit outside I mean first of
all I think one component of the
situated hypothesis is that cognitive
processes are largely externalized
outside of the body and you were just
saying something interesting as well
about um the relationship between
autonomy and being situated can you
expand a little bit on
that yeah well I think um if I'm
situated in an environment and all these
unknown you know factors are kind of
impacting me or at least I'm receiving
you know information from essentially an
unknown environment it seems almost
necessary and and I I guess actually
thinking about it's baked into the free
energy principle which is I need to be
able to adapt I need to be able to have
this autonomy to EV valuate now and
adapt to the new information that I have
whereas I if I have less autonomy and
I'm just kind of set on a particular
course well then I'm just going to crash
into the wall like if I'm self a
self-driving vehicle or something like
is that I mean bird it sounds to me like
that's at least part of kind of the uh
the necessary condition that you're that
you're talking about yeah yeah I mean
it's up to let's say up as far as I know
all Factor we just talked about why we
need to have a factor graph why we need
to have message passing right but as far
as I know all existing toolboxes for
message
passing come with a pre-schedule
uh over the message passing schedule so
you you you you you factorize your model
and then you before you actually do
execute your process you say first I
pass message one going from this note to
this note and then I pass this this
message and then this message and then
this me message now if you are in the
field and you you um you there's a new
there's a cyclist you see you have to
track that cyclist all of a sudden
basically that's a model ex extension
you have to start up a new Calon filter
you would have to reset your message
passing schedule and schedule again and
indeed you will just fly into a wall
because because FR minimization is the
only ongoing thing so if it's not doing
if you're not doing that then you're
doing nothing and you you will just fly
into a wall so we have to
have an autonomous system there cannot
be some pre scheduled message passing uh
schedule right it has to just react to
the circumstances and I think that's
well um I mean you see that in the actor
model and we we call that reactively
reactive programming but uh yeah it's
the same thing it has to be reactive one
thing we were touching on in in the
woods was the I guess the limits of
autonomy and the limits of continual
learning so when an agent develops
maturity um there's this kind of
monotonic increase in behavioral
complexity so essentially the model it
learns is a little bit like a simulacrum
or a map of the environment around it so
it learns a map and you could argue that
the bias increases the variance
decreases so this AG agent now has less
autonomy because the only things it can
do are the things it
knows but that does kind of imply that
agents lose flexibility with maturity
and therefore lose
autonomy yeah I am not I'm I can follow
the argument but I'm not sure if there
aren't any shortcuts in the argument
right um so what the
and I we also talked a bit about that
what how I like to think about this is
from what I understood from a paper by
Rosaline Moran is that as we grow older
so lifelong learning and for older
people um they're going to
encounter less data in the world that
they haven't seen before so there's
going to be less let's say model
building on and working on
accuracy but we will keep working on
that complexity term in the free energy
and so our models will become simpler
and simpler and therefore we generalize
a bit more we are becoming from
Specialists more like generalists we are
able to
connect um uh issues and topics together
because the models become simpler which
is still a matter of I mean it is in
line the lines with fren minimization
you just minimize your
complexity but you're not going to see a
lot of data that's completely
new um so so that that's and I don't
know if that aligns with saying they you
become more stuck in a in a in a in a
rout right um well it feels like that's
not the case I mean it's a really
principle thing to do um many um types
of model training have a kind of
complexity cost in there to right create
this um basically just to when you
reduce the complexity the idea is is
that you generalize more because you're
not overfitting to all of the micro
details so if that is something that
happens over time that seems to imply to
me that the model maintains its
flexibility well let me um let me
interject here because I think uh I
think what your both saying actually is
is right and I think what we need to
inject into this conversation is that if
you think about Evolution right it
doesn't operate on the individual it
operates on the species which is
essentially in the context that we've
just been talking about here it's really
the model generator that it kind of Acts
on so a particular instantiation of a
model you me an actor right a particular
training of GPT whatever it is I think
it does kind of crystallize over time
like it reaches a certain you know it's
a look I this is what I've learned about
the world it's been working because I'm
still alive I've survived and I'm going
to stick with this until basically I you
know I die like until I find out my
model is wrong okay and but the thing is
there's other individuals that have
other models and and they've had a
slightly different you know trajectory
experience set of knowledge and they've
crystallized in different ways right and
so natural selection sort of whittel out
the good from the bad right like it
seems like individual basis Tim I think
what you're saying is absolutely true I
think on like a species or a model
generation basis
I think what what's Bert what you know
berd is saying um can apply as well
right which is that you can transfer
information between individuals and as a
whole continue to develop you know new
models yeah yeah I mean I I think in in
in a in a in a sense we are the the
trials of of of natural selection right
each each each person individually is a
is a trial training trials yeah that
Black Mirror
episode that's right let me pull in let
me pull in another aspect that I that I
realized when you were talking about we
continue to work on the complexity term
we continue to compress and find simpler
models simpler abstractions that you
know capture the the world model that
capture the world that we live in what I
find really intriguing about that is
language is also a form of compression
and most people look at at that as a as
a bad thing like it's like oh you know
language sucks because it's compressed I
can't just directly transfer my pure
thoughts and all their complex
nitty-gritty form over to you it's
really a shame that I have to you know
compress things down into this junky
like ambiguous language and send it to
you um but on the other hand that has a
positive effect because it
forces simplification it forces
reduction in complexity so if you think
about these individuals they spend a
lifetime learning trying testing
improving their models simplifying now
they need to communicate it to other
individuals it's almost a good thing
that it has to be compressed and
simplified to communicate right because
in the end that's the goal which is to
find the simplest models that work
really well could I push back yeah well
could yeah I just wanted to push back on
this idea that language is a form of
compression I I I kind of um I love this
way of thinking that we have these rich
generative models and we use language to
condition others so your your generative
model is conditioned by the fact that I
use a certain word so the information
isn't enclosed in that word it's just a
conditioning Force so I think of
compression as being I'm somehow taking
all of the information and I'm you know
encapsulating it inside something
whereas language seems more like a code
book well I think it's I I don't
disagree that it's a code book but I
think uh when we go to communicate a new
abstraction if you will a new model
we're taking all these codes and we're
we're combining them and these codes are
are limited in their Fidelity right like
if I say to you you know a pile of sand
like I'm not I'm not communicating all
the details of the sand I'm
communicating this this abstraction of
of of a pile of sand and so I think when
we build up these new models with all
these abstracted components that are
approx it that's kind of the the the
compression I'm talking about um and you
know I mean it's like what we struggle
with if I have some complex concept
right you told me this one day Tim you
said uh I'm not very good at explaining
what's in my head you know to to other
people and I think there's Al that's
true there's also um in language this
idea that uh um I mean there's a
digitization in it right so so there's
noise reduction in the same same way
that by digital communication it's it's
useful to know that either a zero or a
one is being sent because if I receive
point8 I'm going to round it to to to to
one and in the same way if if you know
if we just categorize things in this is
a house and that's a car and I uh you
and I would send you a message that is
like well if you know it's only going to
be a house or a car but it's closer to a
car you're just going to round it to a
car so a lot of error
correction in in in communicating
languages right and we have similar
models about about the language and by
communicating in a digital way you you
you uh you you you can uh you come quite
robust to to disturbances yeah and that
and that's a beautiful segue actually to
something I wanted to pick your brain on
a bit more which is you made this
connection from marginalization to
abstraction and you know obviously
marginalization is is a corar graining
but can you can you dive into a bit more
I mean why is why can we view
abstraction as as marginalization you
know what's the connection there it
seems quite
interesting um well no marginalization
is is is is is is uh is is yeah that
leads to abstraction because you you you
factor out variables that provide more
details right this is this is a way of I
mean not not every marginalization is an
abstraction but if you marginalize out
let's say the details out of your model
then you're left with a low pass filter
basically done a low pass filter but not
like a regular low pass filter over time
but just over Concepts so um and over
your variable space and so I I I think
that
um so and and so marginalization is uh
is is needed to um to to to to bring
about hierarchical levels of
abstraction um okay and I think I mean
help me understand something that is
intriguing me here which is in the old
days back when I used to do a lot more
basy and Analysis I always had the model
to start with because you know um I did
some Physics or or some biological
modeling and so I had a model and I also
already had an idea of the variables
that I cared about and those that I
didn't and so for me marginalization
wasn't introducing a new abstraction I
already I already had to had the
abstraction is it possible to discover
new abstractions by instead inverting
that process where I'm looking at you
know variables and figuring out you know
these are
introducing uh like fine grain detail
that aren't important for solving some
problem and in some kind of like
automatic sense figuring out that they
can be marginalized which then leads to
an
abstraction yeah so this is one of the
um advantages of of of let's say doing a
variational
basion or or freen minimization in a
factor graph in in a factor graph
okay um in a factor your probability
distribution is just a product of
factors and each factor just basically
fence for itself and it it sends out
messages and it receives messages these
sending out messages are and you talked
about that as well are the actions and
the receiving of messages are the
sensory inputs now at the back end of
every model you have to set some values
to parameters your hyper parameters
right um sure and so these
hyperparameters can be seen or the
values can be seen as a factor that's
sending out a message saying this is the
the value of this parameter they will
get back from the graph a
message which is going to be interpreted
as what the graph thinks about that
variable and there could be a prediction
error you could see a a hyperparameter
just sending out a value as as as its
action I think this parameter should be
this value and the graph sends back no I
think it should be this value if that
persist
over time you have a good reason to say
I need to extend my model here at the
back end and so this is a way to create
higher levels of extraction or to to um
to to to extend your modelc uh from the
back
end that's that's really interesting and
I think so for our for our listeners um
and and we'll also have some probably
some diagrams on the video but I I think
if you you can just imagine a graph
right and you've got all these nodes and
arrows arrows come in and arrows come
out of nodes and I and I think um you
know if we if I have an arrow coming
into me then I'm a child of the of the
the parent you know that's sending me
this arrow in and you said something
really interesting there and it's it's
the heart of this curious asymmetry in
these um these variational algorithms um
on on you know Bas and graphs right
which is that if I if if if I'm sending
something to a downstream component I
know my my parameters which and let's
just assume for a moment there are a set
of moments you know the mean the
variance maybe some higher order moments
so I know those parameters and so I'm
sending those down and I'm saying this
is what I think you know my model should
be and yet you said something and really
cool there and it's the asymmetry which
is the graph you know your children and
all the the parents of your children are
sending back to you kind of a collective
information that's saying you know hey
glad you think that that's the way it
should be this is the way we think we
think it should be and it's really the
the difference between those that is the
the heart of the optimization algorithm
that's kind of occurring in real time on
this graph is that right yes I mean you
so any probability distribution if you
factorize it you can draw a graph now
you can pull in a facto graph a variable
is associated with the edge and all the
the let's say the the probability
distributions are in the notes so if you
pull if you pull your graph up by the
edge of your variable and then you have
uh sort of two uh trees hanging down
from that edge the left side thinks
something about what that value should
be of for that variable and it will send
a message toward that edge and it
integrates out or it marginalizes over
all the internal variables of that graph
and it says this is the this is the
probability distribution I think this uh
variable this is my belief in this
variable you can think of that as a
prior it's a prediction then the the
other end of the graph it may be
connected to the world and it may have
sensors and it will marginalize over all
the internal variables in that subgraph
and sends back a message and say well
the world the sensory information I got
and then you know processed through my
graphs says this is the
belief I I I think about this variable
and the multiplication of these two
messages is nothing but Bas R it's just
a prior times a likelihood so you're
doing a distributed basan computation in
a factor graph every it's completely
distributed based in computations every
node or every let's every node just
fence for itself but
every variable gets uh a prior and a
likelihood or um if if you will an um a
prediction and a correction right right
right um so yeah that's that's that's a
very good nice interpretation if you do
that at the
edges of your graph at the at the
outside
edges and let's say the prediction from
The Edge
to which is just a
hyperparameter differs significantly
from what the whole graph
thinks of of that the belief should be
then you have a reason to extend your
model right um okay um so so so this is
I mean it's not ex we we're not doing
this in our toolbox yet but this is this
is one way I think where we can go to do
structural adaptation under the drive of
free energy
minimization oh that's fascinating can
you talk can you talk more about that
well we are I mean so we are mainly
interested in the realization of active
influence in my group right so when I
said yeah I'm I'm not a philosopher um
by that I mean I I we don't talk a lot
about
um the the what philosophers talk about
we just want to make it work right what
we talked about earlier we are
interested in making it work um it it
turns out it's actually very hard to
make an active inflence agent work in
the field I think it's reason doable to
make an active inflence agent work as as
a
demo right because then you don't have
the the the the the real world
constraints of the world may may change
and you may have um power budget issues
you have to divide your power budget on
the spot because new situations appear
but in the field it's it's it's quite
difficult um so our toolbox now is is
pretty good in state estimation and and
and parameter updating in pretty much in
real time but structural adaptation is a
real is a real problem I don't think
anybody has as a community we haven't
really tackled that and it's just not
just the active influence Community it's
uh I mean just the whole engineering and
science Community H doesn't have a good
approach yet for online structural
learning right and um well let let me
just get in there for like give me an
example of um an example of online
structural learning that a human being
might do like what's a situation where a
human being demonstrates that that
capability as an as an active
agent well um if you learn how to ride a
bike you you just I mean you don't need
to read a meter of books right you just
go out and start riding a bike um your
your model starts making predictions
when you ride a bike so also predictions
for let's say that you start writing and
you start to fall and I need to well
what what kind of actions can I take
well I can turn my
handlebar
so what your model will do because if
you have a generative model you can
actually Roll It Forward in time and you
can like roll out the different
scenarios under the various actions you
can take namely how how far do you turn
your
handlebar
um in the beginning your model is all
wrong so you're going to make big
prediction errors sure it's all wrong
these prediction errors get processed
they get processed by updating States if
these if they still persist you will
have to update your parameters if they
still persist well eventually you have
to make updates to the structure of of
your model because in the end an active
insance an active insurance agent is
only interested in making good
predictions
right so it's it's it the first step is
just to update your States then to
update your parameters but in the long
run we're going to have to make have to
um um update our model and if our model
something say something interesting too
about this this situation is so I'm
trying to learn how to ride a bike
there's really a relatively small at
least in a qualitative sense a
relatively small number of um things I
can do actions I can take right like
it's either I can move this arm or this
arm or pedal this foot or that foot a
little bit faster or harder like it's
it's it's quite a manageable set of
actions I can take though they're
continuous so maybe there's a bit of you
know Nuance to that but but it's
interesting that the model is is I hate
to say compressed again but it's
compressed through this this filter of a
very small number of actions that it can
actually take um in the world right
well I'm not so sure if that's really
the case because the I mean you can also
move your your body on the bike and you
can move your point of gravity and and
your point of gravity will affect how
much you will need to turn your
handlebars um so it's very complex
relationship between the position of
your body
the how big the bike is with the slope
of your of the street and the um and the
speed that you're taking and how far you
have to move the handlebar so it's just
whole this whole physics complex and
it's it's nonlinear it's very
complicated nonlinear it's very
situational right it's very I mean you I
mean it depends on the particular bike
you're riding and the
particular um road that you're Drive
riding on the slope um everything um so
generally once you know how to write a
bag you can make these adaptations
pretty quickly but if you have to learn
it from
scratch you may have to do some I mean
it may take a few weeks because you may
have to do well at least some serious
parameter updating and perhaps even some
structural
updating right um interesting once that
works though and your predictions are
all correct I mean then you can write
your bike without even thinking about it
right it doesn't because your
predictions are correct means that you
almost generating your prediction errors
are very small so there's no processing
to be done and so there's no computing
power to be spent the things that you
learn to do
well um the skills over time they will
cost less less and less energy in the
brain and that's also really good right
in engineering that's usually not the
case but um once
you yeah so so tell me why I mean
because what are
you know what are the biggest challenges
to Real Time online structure learning
in in the engineering in the engineering
case you know like like in a sense
what's the magic trick that that life
forms can do that we haven't yet figured
out how to do um in silico if you will
the the the example that that that I
like is is is the human body and i' say
that tries to control is to be in for
home stasis right um which is a Control
process that is beyond anything that
Engineers will ever built right I mean
we have 10 million sens Sensory neurons
processed by what is it 80 billion uh
internal neurons and then relate to
50,000 muscle spindles so it's beyond
anything that we will ever buil
apparently the brain does that just by
variational free energy minimization on
a computational budget of what is it
maximum 20 watts and does it in real
time
so we we have here something that we can
never ever I mean we're not even close
right with our control theory with our
machine learning to to build a a control
system like this so the
difficulty is to do interesting things
that means to to to minimize variational
free energy
um on a on a low power budget in real
time and minimize variational free
energy for the processes that
matter right it doesn't matter whether
the car
that that that I'm looking at if is blue
or red but it matters but if he's coming
in my direction or not so spend your
resources just at the stuff that matters
and be able to interrupt at any time for
stuff that matters even more right and
this is this is quite different
from what we I mean how how most of us
think about um designing good algorithms
in engineering we just think about high
accuracy but not oh I need to be able to
interrupted and switch to another
process I need to be able to do the same
algorithm but now on 30% of its power or
I need to be able to do the same
algorithm but now the car that comes at
me drives 120 km an hour instead of 80
so I have a an a shorter
deadline so when all
these constraints the computational
resources that you have in power time
data when that differs all the time and
you have changing have a different um
environment around
you you you still want to have a
performing um um agent or even set of
Agents and and that means they need to
be very robust that they need to work on
50% of the power as well and they need
to also work if I if I if I have a a
smaller deadline um so that that I think
is U where I see the most promise for
active inference we're not there yet we
I mean I think active inference is is is
is a fantastic future but we're not
there yet in implementing agent so in
such a distributed way and so always
interruptable uh free minimization Over
States parameters and when needed over
structures
um and stopping processes that that are
not important right um so this um H this
is a big this a big challenge right so
so and that's what at least in my group
we try to focus on try to build a
generic
toolbox that would scale and that would
do as much freen minimization as we can
for a small power budget or for a small
uh temporal budget that's the that's
really really fascinating and I think
that's also where this field differs
from generative AI because in a sense
active influence is also generative AI
but now it's generative AI in the field
right it's the next I think wave of
generative AI when we take this models
this diffusion models and all these
models into the field and now we have a
power budget because we they r on
batteries so do we we also run on
batteries right and uh and there are
deadlines now and
that's that that's very tough because
the deadlines are not predictable and
the budget is not
predictable and so um that requires a
new computational approach I think
active
inference is very promising in that
respect because everything is
variational free enery minimization and
you can implement it in very small units
of time in a very distributed way so
from a computational
perspective it's it's just a path
toward I mean toward getting agents to
survive in a world where everything can
change on a limited power budget MH
right so have no I have no in a sense I
have no um argument or complaint with
AI but we need to take it if if you take
it into a
field you can easily create a world
where it will fall apart and and this is
the robustness that's currently not
there and I think active inference is
just hopefully is going to be a way to
make that transition to to well to
situated
agents yeah it's really fascinating I
mean and and everything you've been
talking about it seems to me the key
is better methods and techniques to
design and Implement algorithms it's not
you know it's not a case of like well we
just
need more smaller CPUs and and you know
faster CPUs and maybe like some gpus in
there and like and stuff like that it's
not it's not a hardware issue
fundamentally this is really an
algorithmics issue it's it's an
algorithmic design issue is that correct
I think so yes I mean the the it's it's
a completely different approach to to
programming right it's it's a New
Concept which also
means that it's going to be hard to
introduce this in the engineering
community I mean we just we we aren't
even out of the discussion yet with
let's say the control theory Community
about why don't you use a cost function
or a reward function right I I mean this
is a discussion that that I think active
inference Community has very good
answers for but we haven't been able to
convince the um the control Community
fully yet on the other hand um now we
need to implement it and we need to talk
to software engineers and and and
Hardware engineers and we're going to
have a similar Mountain to overcome now
because we actually we're
saying we don't want to write these
procedural algorithms we want to write a
self organized ing system right
um and that yeah that's that's going to
be difficult you know and I mean we were
talking about this over lunch but I
think one shift over the next five years
is we're moving towards this ecosystem
view of software which is that software
is grown it's not designed and I think
we're going to see all sorts of
interesting scaling bottlenecks because
we basically have all of these agents
that are diffusing information but when
I say diffusing I mean sometimes they're
not directly passing information it's
going over several time steps via other
agents so information is diffusing in
the system but there are weird
bottlenecks and as a developer now when
me it's really interesting as a
developer your life has just completely
changed over the last few years now
you're using language models but soon
you'll be like a neurosurgeon so rather
than just understanding how the software
works you'll just be looking at this
thing you'll be looking at these
behaviors and you'll be trying to swap
out agents and try to you know affect
changes by poking the system rather than
just directly changing it so um yeah I
think it'll be quite interesting how how
this pans
up yeah and I think the the scary part
is going to be when when we have to
start talking about the psychology of
our of our software systems right like
you know let's try to let's try to
understand the emergent behavior of our
um of our software systems um yeah yeah
but that is but just on that key we are
talking about emergence right we're
talking about oh yeah these very
lowlevel simple prediction models that
give rise to extremely complex Behavior
but I think a lot of the confusion when
people talk about it as you pointed out
with the evolution example earlier is
that things happen at different scales
of
emergence yeah so so I think you know
individual models I think of as being
quite um inflexible but when you look at
the process that generated the models
then it is flexible so I think our
mindset is changing with software that
we're starting to increasingly view
things in a more abstract level yeah
yeah so so I think there's going to be
less algorithm writing yes and more more
um indeed like talking about what is
desired behavior of these um so there
are these nice pictures of a lighting a
lightning strike um with all the
branches right if it's at the right
moment and the you you can kind of this
is also energy neutralization right
there a big potential and just
neutralized over the Earth and so um you
can see this as um research and cutting
branches and everything and that's I
think that's ex that's also what's going
on but nobody designed that algorithm
nobody wrote a depth first search and
then when this happens I do this or
there is no no that's just just
following the
physics and and it follows the physics
of well we neutralize energy differences
of any kind in in least time that's the
physics right and well and how that
invols so it invols yeah and this is the
kind of software that we have to write
and so that's difficult
because most of the
reinforcement learning literature is is
about algorithms to search Tre trees and
to cut
trees rather than software of of of of
of of autonomous nodes that kind of
resolve it locally right that say oh the
prediction are is so small we can stop
here guys nothing to see anymore we we
this is a really interesting idea that
we're talking about self-organizing
software which is very similar to Steven
Wolf's Ry ad which is this idea that you
can think of the universe in a
constructivist way so lots of uh simple
rules that over time construct to
produce incredible complexity or you can
think of the universes all of the things
that could possibly happen and you can
kind of progressively remove it until
you get to the universe that that that
we um that we live in now but um but we
were talking about algorithms and in
deep learning you get this weird hybrid
you have Monte Carlo tree search or you
have tree of thought which is basically
an AAR search and there's there's always
explicit kind of planning algorithms
built on the top of even with a language
model how do we Traverse the um you know
all of these tokens it's a beam search
and I would imagine but you corrected me
earlier I would have imagined that even
in a multi-agent active inference setup
you would do some kind of a beam search
against some kind of um planning
function in order to select the best
trajectory but you're kind of saying
that's not the
case no I I I I think it's not the case
yeah I I think we shouldn't try to write
these three search algorithms I think
this the the thing is that even in the
case of let's say this lightning strike
it's the so you it goes around it it
tries a branch it's an explorative
Branch but that I ionizes the field
around it that affects yes yes the I
mean the thing is an agent affects the
environment that affects the agent and
so forth so you get in this Loop you
just have to let it unfold until there's
no more opportunity to minimize free
energy and then then stops but so so
this is really interesting because you
know there's this Chinese room argument
and people say John S in the room
doesn't actually understand and what
you're saying is that we should get to a
point where no individual agent actually
plans and but the but the planning is
diffused so the planning is in the
system because even if the individual
bits only did what they were to do in
the moment I I my my take on friston is
that he's saying that they do develop
this kind of you know temporal planning
capability it looks like that yeah but I
think I think look look the there's one
thing in in in in active inference and
also in reinforcement learning you
you um you say well um I want to attain
a certain state in the future right
whether you do it by a reward function
or by by some constraint on a
probability distribution say we we we
have these states in the future and we
we we're going to constrain them in some
way and now I'm going to
predict uh and and kind of refer and
then work backwards what kind of action
should I take now to to up the chances
that I will get in that state yeah
um the the impression that I get from
the literature is that people always
start with saying okay we capital T
that's our Horizon right or um um and
then we go predict we collect that
reward and we go back as if it starts
with setting the Horizon and then the
prediction collecting the reward or
measuring the reward it's I think it's
the other way around you we we you
shouldn't set the Horizon there's not um
why should you predict the future if
there's no information there you should
just wait until some other agent on some
other set of notes says I have some
information about these
states right you you should keep your
feet off the ground if you want to ride
a bike in the future so
H okay then that will instigate some
message passing there because now there
is an opportunity for free enery
minimization it's not but nobody sets
The Horizon it's just the process that
happens to put some information there
yeah and I guess that that's what I mean
by the diffusion of planning yes yeah so
it's it's it's fascinating isn't it that
it it's it's really fascinating and I
think um you can actually you know we we
know this in computer science because
for example think of all the algorithms
that are divide and conquer right like
the idea is I'm trying to look for some
Global solution and the way I should do
that is to divide it up into a bunch of
sub problems and then solve those and
then divide those up recursively into
sub problems you know so dynamic
programming quick sort you know all
these things and so the idea is I can
just keep repeating this little simple
algorithm at the very bottom and then
get a solution and go up to the next
level and the next level and the next
level and in a way that's that's what
we're talking about here which is which
is what type of kind of simple set of
rules can you put into an ant so that if
you take 5,000 ants you know you get you
get a colony and it's doing this kind of
interesting interesting stuff right yeah
yeah and I think that's I mean so so in
the end that and almost every level that
you look
at um every layer or every
note you always say well this system is
just trying to predict its world and
it's it it's it gets corrected by
sensory inputs whether they come from a
lower layer or from other noes or from
sensors it
just it makes predictions gets
prediction errors they get processed
that's it there's nothing else going on
right there's one twist and that is that
there is encoded a certain goal of
staying alive or or or what is success a
setting constraints and that makes this
active inference Loop not an objective
let's say scientific inquiry Loop but it
makes it an automated engineer it makes
it an engineering Loop because now there
is a purpose automated engineer like
that no but really really right I mean
the um the actions are the the the the
the if it would if there wouldn't be
constraints then you would just have a
you would build a model of the world in
an almost optimal way right you you you
you you make your actions those are your
trials and
you uh you get your sensory observations
right and and you process them both in
an optimal way but because of the
constraint there is a bias and now it
has a purpose it's still
doing the the the the objectively best
process the the basian process but now
with this constraint it turns into a
purpose it turns into a vacuum cleaner
or you know whatever it is a drone um
and so active inference to me is an
automated Engineering Process which is
why we can develop with our brains um
speech recognition algorithms and object
recognitions and and navigation
algorithms and Locomotion and and all
these things they have a purpose MH so
the the brain is an automated engineer
now through an active
and I've often uh I've
often sort of thought that the only and
and I I first started thinking about
that I was I was working at IBM for a
little while and it was at the time when
they were developing um the blue you
know blue things like um um deep blue
and and blue jean and all these kind of
supercomputers and one day I was
chatting with some of the engineers
there and they were talking about you
know as they scaled to larger and larger
systems for every single CPU they added
to do something useful they had to add a
CPU to handle the communication of that
CPU to like other CPUs right and then
and then you know then they needed a CPU
for that guy and so there was a kind of
you know it became very difficult to
scale
monolithic sort of sort of structures
and and so the only truly kind of
infinitely scalable control is
distributed control of exactly the kind
that we're talking about where you just
you kind of push out control as far down
to the bottom layer of the tree if you
will as you can and then let let kind of
these larger scale Control Systems um
self assemble or you know emerge you
know from this these distributed control
programs and so I have a tremendous
amount of sympathy you know for this
approach like I'd like to see it applied
even more broadly like to say I don't
know political structures like maybe we
should distribute the control a bit more
and like not keep trying to create you
know more and more control that's
topheavy right because it just doesn't
scale it doesn't produce optimal results
it's not not flexible it's not adaptable
um yeah yeah I mean could could we touch
on another couple of things because um
what you were saying there is very
interesting Keith and earlier on we
touched on this notion of a scaling
bottleneck or an an information sharing
bottleneck and um when we were in the
car as well we were talking about the
robustness of the real world is because
we don't
explicitly program in purposes and this
stack of intermediate sub goals they are
learned because when we build active
inference systems we need to start by
handcrafting almost the entire stack the
goals the sub goals we bias the system
and then when we have something that
works it you know it's an agent-based
framework so it'll still be
significantly more robust than this
monolithic approach that Keith was
talking about but eventually we want to
start introducing variant we want to
remove the the biases and I was thinking
that one of the reasons that the natural
world is so robust is because the agents
are themselves nested um everything is
seeded from the microscopic scale so
even we as agents are composed of a
hierarchy of sub agents and in the
artificial setting as I just said we fix
a whole load of the goals and layers but
the agents are also um atomic
so how do all of these things affect
things like scaling bottlenecks
resilience robustness I think I mean if
you imple if I take that as let's say a
factor graph approach which is which is
nothing but saying it's just a divide
and conquer approach right so you have a
factorized model and each each um all
the processing is just factors nodes
sending messages to other nodes to to
Connected node that's the only
processing that's going
on you can do in that node whatever you
want as long as the API is good as long
as the other notes thinks you are a
regular note in a factor graph it's fine
we we are currently experimenting
putting gaussian processes in in those
noes I mean they they are
nonparametric models they're very
different from the the the parametric
models but nobody knows that in the
graph because as long as on the outside
just look like a factor note you know it
if it cracks like a duck and it walks
like a duck yes right so be a subgraph
yeah yeah yeah so that's that's one
thing the the the other thing is of
course that
[Music]
um so if you do this in a reactive way
and you don't have a
preset schedule then any schedule
is you just follow the physics right so
if you pick if you take out a note uh
because you burn run out a transistor
fine it takes a different route it's
just a switch to a different model so in
a sense structural adaptation is the
other side of the same coin as as
robustness because burning out an edge
or a note is also a structural
adaptation right and and
so
um yeah so there's a diffusion of
function and there's um there's a clear
information architecture there's an
interface I mean in versus for example
they've got this spatial um you know
kind of schema for want of a better word
so there's a clear interface so I can
see how that um gives you a lot of
resiliency by the way we haven't talked
about K in over two years on MLS te you
you just Pi when you're talking about
calcium processes it just made me
realize that we're so far away from our
early roots in machine learning but H
we'll we'll we'll wander back there W
back there
so I think um there's kind of two things
I'd like to hit on uh before before we
leave and one is I'm always ranting
about this that there are no silver
bullets okay like every you know no free
lunch theorem no silver bullets like
like that sort of thing so back at the
beginning we talked about you know
basium methods tell you you have to do
this impossible integral which we can't
do and so we have this variational
message passing which is which is one
framework that uh can give us efficient
Solutions but there has to be a tradeoff
and and I know that part of the
trade-off is there are certain models
that that work well like in a
variational message passing like
traditionally it's models that are
conjugate you know these are things that
have forms let's say just for the
listener similar to Gans you just
mentioned you know um Gan uh mixture
models and things like that um typically
they work better with linear systems
versus nonlinear but I know that a lot
of your research has been kind of
expanding that that Frontier like
finding kind of
clever uh you know tricks and clever
heris to make variational message
passing work with larger and larger
classes of models like can you talk
about you know where where are we at
today you know where's kind of the
state-of-the-art of how like the how
broad the categories of models we can
handle are and if you could find a trick
tomorrow to add one extra you know class
of models that we can't current L do
what class of models would you choose to
kind of slip in
there um so so the I mean the toolbox
that we we are working on it's U it's
called RX infer RX stands reactive
extensions and infer adult uh ml machine
learning so it's a it's it's a toolbox
for variational free energy minimization
in probabilistic models that's that's it
and it can of course be applied to
active influence doesn't have to be
applied in that context right at the
moment we
are pretty good in let's say doing
message passing in in in in in almost
everything that relates to the
exponential family of distributions
which
are which are most distributions that
people have heard of right like bruli
distributions and gaussians and GMA and
and whizard and and all these
distributions that works very well you
can also put nonlinearities
deterministic nonlinearities in between
those factors with nonlinearities like
logarithm or an exponent or
sigmoid if you put these together you
have
already very large set of models right
so so so we can do a pretty large set of
models and not everything works as
accurate as as as as not everything
works in the same kind of accuracy
because if you go through nonlinearities
you have to make more adaptations and we
also want to do it fast so there are
tradeoffs that we're working on in the
end what we want to do is make a toolbox
where the inference is auto automated
you because in in non-al models you you
you you cannot do you cannot derive it
anymore by hand right so we want to have
uh people come up with a generative
model well what's that half a page of
code that's not much and then you
say yeah uh you hook it up to your
sensors and actuators and you push a
button and you say optimize for Speed or
optimize for time or for for accuracy
yes right and if you say optimize for
Speed then we take the fast way it's
going to going to cost you a bit of
accuracy you optimize for um for
accuracy well may have we may do some
sampling even in between just just to
get
in
ideally if you are in the field with
your a agent the agent should even make
that decision and it should be context
dependent right so so there the there is
a path that we want to take to letting
the a so that the engineer will just
have to worry about the model and no
longer think about the inference that
should because it's too
hard
for engineers to actually derive the
right algorithm when the world changes
mhm um it's also hard to educate people
during a master's program to become
really good at variational free energy
minimization in the real
world um and if we want one of the
successes of course of of deep learning
is that every graduate student can now
design um a solution with a deep neural
network if we want active inference to
to to have an impact and get go to
situated agents then it must be
democratized we must have graduate
students implementing these agents so
I'm I'm happy to teach them
about generative
models but I'm not so happy to teach
them about how to manually derive
inference in these models and even so so
so there's there's a limitation um I'm
also not so
sure um if we should focus on building
an even even bigger model scope because
that was your original question what
what would be the next model to be I'm
not sure if we should focus on bigger
model scope and bigger model scope or
let's start building agents and let the
world tell us what works and not because
we may already be be there and we would
be building all kinds of machinery for
models that we don't need right yes okay
I mean just a quick clarifying question
so um there have been probabilistic
programming libraries for for a long
time I played around with one called
info.net which was by Microsoft research
Cambridge I think Thomas minker team was
developing that and that had a lot of
the same kind of stuff so approximate
inference with variational message
passing and so on so people were using
that just to do generic probabilistic
programming and we're talking about this
active inference framework um so when
when does the probabilistic programming
stop and when does active inference
start and when does the agent framework
starts you see what I mean there's this
kind of like little ladder that we need
to climb up in in a way I think
um um writing software for an active
inflence agents is probabilistic
programming right I mean you whenever
you
have variables and you don't assign
values but you assign probability
distributions and you want to calculate
what how these probability distributions
propagate through your your your uh your
model you're doing probabilistic
programming right um yeah infer net of
course was uh the the success of infer
net on on various large problems was
quite a motivation for us but
um we we we for active inference it's
it's all about going into the field and
so so it's all about doing free energy
minimization or message passing under
power constraints under deadlines uh
temporal constraints data constraints um
missing observations notes that burn out
and and still still have a let
everything keep everything working right
that's yeah I think the where we want to
differ with with with our work
um it's not done right I mean this is a
this is a long-term uh this is a
long-term project um so more generally I
think active inference is
um is a really new field that's a
fantastic
future but the implementation is
something that people haven't really
thought about yet very deeply and the
implementation is not not very simple
it's so so that's that's that may be
um we need a lot more research um to to
get this really working I mean
Deployable agents that really adapt in
the in the way that we want to right I
mean yeah yeah even with them sorry k I
was just going to say I'm just curious
are you are you finding it difficult you
know because you're a professor and so
you're you're you're trying to educate
your students and you want to do right
by them so you want to try and teach
them about active inference because you
you believe that it's that it's a you
know a tool for the future I'm just
curious if you're running into much
resistance um and and I don't know
getting people interested in it or uh or
teaching it or getting funding for
projects you know related to active do
you see a lot of resistance or do you
see
open-mindedness um both but um certainly
a lot of yeah um um I wouldn't say um
resistance but not ill-willed resistance
just just skepticism right skepticism
yeah and um so it's very hard to attract
good students because there are much
easier ways to get a master's degree
than uh with bu and you can get a much
easier result
um um with a deep neural net if the
world doesn't change all right and if
you if and if you don't have an uh let's
say a power budget then I think you
should use a deep net it's fine um but
so yeah so in the choices we made we
made them like eight years ago was okay
we're going to do active inference that
nobody understands we're going to
implement it
with fact graphs
nobody nobody really knows about we're
going to program it in Julia instead of
python because Julia is fast and python
is not and then we're going to do it in
a reactive programming style so oh de So
nich within a niche within a niche h n
with
a so but it is it is of course a problem
then to to to get a student and get him
even started right I think even then
though so reactive programming is is a
phenomenon that's taken off in many
different languages but I I I guess what
I'm saying is is that if if you're a
grad student in your early 20s picking
up a new language isn't going to be a
problem I think I always felt when I
played around with probabilistic
programming that the bottleneck was the
modeling and also just all of the kind
of the general knowledge you need around
you know you need to know about basanis
and Factor graphs and um it's it's just
not easy no no no but I mean
the look the
long-term impact on
engineering could be enormous right in
in in in Academia for instance because
active inference says Hey a control
system that's just prediction and error
correction uh Speech processing is
prediction and error correction uh
computer vision is prediction and error
correction so so so so so we all these
different disciplines are sort of have
now a new approach and we could even
make a good case of why it's a very good
approach
um now to to to so so I would
advise students yeah go go in this
direction but um it's it's not an easy
Direction Just A difficulty I mean let
me ask you this question which is I
would think I would think that as the
world increasingly relies on embedded
devices low power devices internet of
things you know just uh as it becomes
more almost electroni in a distributed
way like more and more things become you
know digital systems your therat your
smart home like cameras over here
whatever like this has to help at least
put some pressure to embrace um active
inference because that's that's its
natural you know swimming swimming plane
right is is or not yeah yeah I think so
I mean I think blockchain also right
blockchain is a distributed ledgers um
um I Heard the other day the the CTO of
algorand say yeah algorand is really
just a distributed um operating system
right and I
I I'm not sure if you can run uh uh
active in distributed active inference
agents on on algorand so don't know
really anything about it but there is of
course there is a tendency to or or
there is quite some research going on uh
in in in in bu making systems more
distributed and it will have an impact
on uh on on robustness on on power
consumption on shared and emerging
intelligence so yeah yeah but could
could we tease apart because I'm very
excited about distributed systems and
and I and and also if they are agent
Frameworks that's very EXC exting to me
but what is the cash value exactly of
the active
inference over just any distribut to I
mean for example you could have an agent
framework where we have agents that are
using open ai's new language model Bots
that they I think it's the fact
that all the processing is variational
free engine minimization there's no
other process going on and variation of
free minimization can be
executed in a distributed way so
parallel distributed and also so and and
also with through message passing and
colliding messages in
very minor or very small time instance
which means it's always interruptible
you can
deal you can you you you can just cut a
process short you have a less accurate
result but you have a
result if I do some depth first search
and I cut it halfway I'm just well I'm
not even there yet it's right so so you
can you need a process
that it's doing active doing free free
minimization yeah on a global scale but
it's also doing it locally spatially
locally at any note and any small unit
of time and so it can be cut and
morphed in in in in in in in yeah in all
the ways that the world can change yes
so something you were just saying it's
very very similar concept I think to to
this notion of Subs symbolic so Subs
symbolic is this idea that your
knowledge and computation is diffused
over many nodes and that's neon Network
connectionist people always said Sub sub
symbolic systems are great because um we
have this kind of diffusion and then um
Kathy came along and said well yes it's
software 2.0 uh you can now spfy the
network you can delete half of the
connections and it still does the thing
you want it to do just not quite as well
as before so that seems like quite a
related concept to what you're saying
about the the diffusion of um you know
processes in in a in a
system yeah and the with with the the
side remark that if you go out in the
field and and and and you have a
changing world around you that you're
forced to do these prunings and forced
to cut short and forced to say no you
just get one Watts one watt instead of
two watt now and a moment later you get
two Watts um so you're forced to to to
um you have all these
fluctuating computational resources and
um and and and so so it's it's true you
the neural net works when let's say when
you take out half the connections but
we're dealing with a situation where it
where where the number of connections
fluctuates continuously yes right or at
least the effect connections fluctuate
continuously because we're forced to
that's the best way to go but but are
you making the argument of robustness
which is that you can remove some of the
things and the process won't be affected
or are you making the argument that what
the process is doing is kind of not only
diffused over the entire system but
progressively computed which means it
gives you as an engineer more
flexibility to say actually I'm going to
remove half of the nodes or I'm going to
stop processing now and I've still got
something useful well the way so let me
jump in because the way I look at this
and and tell me if this is this is wrong
Bert is I think about the old school you
know GIFs that used to progressively
come into focus on on the web right so
you would go to a web page back when
things were really slow and you would
get kind of this low resolution vision
of the image and then the resolution
would kind of double and then double and
after a bit it would be the full
resolution and I think the point is I
could have stopped it at any point along
that chain Progressive and have like a
decent image right that's exact it
wouldn't be high that's exactly it right
and it's just I
mean you don't have to m i mean
I
so it's okay if I mean if you if you
have all the computational power in the
world it's you you can track this this
car very accurately and you can do so
because you have a lot of computation
but in the end if your computational
power shrinks you just want to miss that
car right
that's the only thing you care about so
so so so you don't you don't care about
if it's a beautiful car or where its
headlights are you just want to miss it
right so so the the amount of
computation you do you want to scale it
down and uh and and indeed at the
resolution that is just needed to
to well to not hit that car right that's
the only that's the highest resolution
that you need ultimately right um yeah
yeah and the other thing too is and and
this is kind of kind of a a minor point
but it's one that is important I think
and and should be realized is that
because you mentioned the depth for
search when you go to run a a prediction
or a score let's say on you know a
neural network okay it has to perform
every single one of its layer steps in
order to get the result if you halt it
in any intermediate step there you have
no result you just have a bunch of you
know more or less meaningless bits that
haven't yet haven't yet been combined
now that like today that may not be a
big deal because maybe still neural
networks only have some dozens of layers
or something but at some point if you've
got very very deep neural networks you
know that inability to stop it in it at
any point along the phase means that the
entire computation is either completed
and worth something or just worthless
and got got halted you
know yeah exactly exactly right so you
you want to process that that is always
interruptible and that that also runs
when the computational resources
fluctuate right um oh that too yeah so
you may be able to take out half the uh
half the you know connections or
something can you take out half the
layers you know um and can you take out
half the data right if I if I I'm
driving and I see a guy coming at me
with his car but I also see in the rear
view mirror a car behind me that's
speeding up I I may say okay I'm going
to just check every two seconds in this
rear viiew mirror and that means I'm
going to get less data from the car in
front of me so we're also trading off
how much sampling how much sampling do I
do in the world right so it's there's
there's data fluctuations there's
deadline or temporal fluctuations and
there's power fluctuations all the
computational resources and
um yeah that's that's the I think the
where the research needs to go if if
we're talking
about getting to really
robust situated active inflence agents
right yeah so fascinating it's very
similar to what Michael Levan talks
about in terms of morphogenesis and the
robustness of biological agents um you
know for example they can self-heal
and you're talking is that is that the
cellular autometa that that that self
heal like the salamander and whatnot
that's a great example of yeah kind of
morphogenesis in um a CNN yes so cool
yeah I I talk about it all the time so
I'm not I'm not going to bore bore the
listeners with it yet again but um but
but no this this this idea that systems
can be robust and I've never really
heard people SP speak about this before
but but you're saying robust in terms of
um where I sample the data the time
resolution and even the data resolution
so being resilient to all of those and
power yeah and in order for you to be
resilient to all those different
dimensions there has to be some kind of
a diffusion of how that processing is
done in respect of those dimensions and
that's if you look at any software
engineering systems today today that
just doesn't that's just not the case
right if you change any of those things
it'll just break yeah yeah yeah and it's
like the ultimate it's like the ultimate
divide and conquer like dividing up on
every single Dimension so and it's also
I think when we talk about okay what is
the killer app for active influence
agents because I mean it's it's not
going to really fly with
a with with let's say with with a
control Community until we have also
until active influence also has a killer
app right and it would be one of those
things where you you you scale down the
um or you have a very limited amount of
resources and you just you just throw
over your world so it has to start up
all these common filters and then I
think you you will see that an active
insurance
agents more gracefully can can uh or
will be more robust to to to messing up
the world right yes so at least that's
the goal if we can do
that with our toolbox or other people
with a toolbox if we can come up with a
toolbox that does that then I think
active influence agents have a very good
future yes so let me let me throw out a
c a crazy idea and just tell me if this
is if I'm totally wrong but what I think
what I think you're saying is that if
suppose we figure this out and we have
active inference and we know how to
build active inference um agents that
can you know learn to do a very broad
range of tasks could I for example take
an active inference agent uh hook it up
to a car um let it learn how to
self-drive a car and once it gets pretty
good at that I now take it and maybe I
throw it into an airplane and it's
actually able to learn how to fly the
airplane kind of reasonably well pretty
quickly Just Having learned how to drive
a car like is that the type of
robustness of of kind of system we're
talking about I think
there's well I wouldn't I wouldn't do it
as a as a first experiment but well no
no of course no no but in principle of
course there's a lot of skills that are
transferable right I mean I I also
talked to to Tim about that there is
this experiment with a feret they take
the optic nerve and they hook it up to
through the thalamus to the auditory
cortex and then the feret start to see
again because the auditory auditory
cortex will just start to serve as a as
a visual cortex because the cortex is
just a prediction engine it doesn't
really know whether it's busy with with
with auditory dat or actic data or
visual data it's just data that strives
to predict and in that sense I think a
lot what you learn while driving a
car you I mean it will also transfer to
uh what you what you need to know when
you drive an airplane or or probably
better yet let's say a moped or
something right it's the same kind of
traffic and so so that will transfer
quite well yeah yeah we were talking
about this earli Keith but you know um
Jeff Hawkins has this idea that um you
know these pyramidal neurons and the
prefrontal cortex they they all
basically look the same and they're all
connected to different sensory motor
circuits um he said there was about
150,000 mini columns column units um but
anyway that the point is is that they're
all the same and they can be specialized
for language or basically anything but
to me that says because you said they
don't know they don't know about seeing
or driving but I would argue this is
this is a great example of the
externalization of cognitive processes
the knowledge isn't in the brain cells
the knowledge is in your eyeballs in the
way the roads are structured the signs
all of these external cognitive
processes all the signals come into your
brain and then a map is created a
simulacrum of the outside world and then
we look at the brain and we say that's
the knowledge but it's not it's it's
just a representation of the situation
I'm in yeah that's and and that kind of
explains why you could connected to any
set of neurons and they would just take
on the same
specialization yeah I mean we walk about
I mean every day we have new situations
new situations and we we go through it
effortlessly effortlessly right so yeah
um yeah well um are there any other big
topics that you want to cover if not I
have just just a personal fun question
at the end here there is I mean
this thing that I I I think of uh what
the impact could be for let's say for
engineers um and um
designing algorithms in the future right
um nowadays when you Des when you have
to design a hearing aid algorithm
because I happen to know about that but
it's it's it's it's it's more it's it's
very general if you you you have to hire
Engineers for all the modules for noise
reduction for for feedback cancellation
Etc and then when you print all the code
out you have 40 50 pages of code right
and then half the team leaves for better
jobs or whatever and so over
time nobody really knows the whole code
base anymore technical debt right in the
future if these agents start to work an
engineer would write an uh a generative
model which is half a page of code or
maximum a page and then you would press
a button you say do variational free
energy minimization and yes that's still
the the the toolbox is still 50 pages of
code but it's variation of free
minimization is the same for robotics as
for hearing aids as for for it's just
it's just logic it's just probability
Theory so you have completely separated
your problem definition in your
generative model from the process of of
proper reasoning about your problem
right so on on that very interesting now
there is in a in a software development
project there is a shared understanding
of what the code does and that
understanding is diffused in the brains
of the developers yeah so no one
developer has a complete understanding
God knows Keith always tells me when I
break some of his code that I fail to
understand something and vice versa and
um you know even more so a lot of the
code is generated by GPT models which
only further diffuses degrades the code
I write I'm sorry not to well I mean
dgar would never admit to it anyway but
um but no anyway like we no one you know
in a in a large project the the
understanding is actually not not very
high but you're talking about this new
mod modality where we kind of train it's
a little bit like training a dog that we
we optimize certain behaviors and we
kind of like say we want more of that we
want less of that and we don't
understand how a dog's brain
works I guess is there a kind of
chauvinism for striving to understand
what the code
does you how can you explain what you
mean by chauvinism well by by chauvinism
I mean like um we we think that we are
good software Engineers if we completely
understand how all of the code works and
maybe I mean on any reasonably sized
software project that's impossible yeah
yeah okay I I so so um so so you you're
saying a software engineer perhaps
doesn't need to understand everything of
the code I think that's true I mean um
most companies work perfectly well with
not every software engineer
understanding all of the code base but
the the the main thing is that you can
now design a system an an agent where
your proprietary code for your company
is this one page of code and you can you
can even go to the
CEO and say look this is this is how we
Define uh the generative model of our
vacuum
cleaner and we we just licens some
toolbox that does free energy
minimization and but and there's there's
people that there other companies that
do that and it has nothing to do with
vacuum cleaning but we need it so we
just license it but but it's much easier
to maintain that one page of code that
generative model that and and and and
and file a patent for it if you will um
but but you need a much smaller group
group of of of Engineers to start up a
company and develop a
product yeah okay because it's kind of
related to you know like with deep
learning the model doesn't have any
value it's that you train it on data and
then the the behavior emerges but you're
you're talking about this middle way
where you could have a domain specific
model uh which is a generative model and
it would work almost out of the box or
with minimal training and it would adapt
and personalized to the users's
requirements the the the point is that
um a haate company shouldn't need
Engineers that focus on variation of
free energy minimization they should
hire Engineers that focus on what is a
proper model right so so so we need to
educate Engineers for um gener for for
for generative building generative
models but
only a different set of Engineers should
specialize in let's make better
toolboxes for variational free energy
minimization but it has nothing to do
with hearing aids or yeah with and now
we have to also
put good algorithm engineers in in in in
in hearing a companies and in vacuum
cleaner companies and and and everywhere
right so um it's it's
more it just it just makes the the the
technical staff just leaner and and and
and more focused on the core business of
the company
you know one point though Tim about this
kind of you know chauvinism for code you
know me personally I'm okay with the
idea that I don't personally understand
an an entire code base but what I do
want is that every bit of code was
understood by some human expert who
designed that code and I'll tell you why
because as good as neural networks are
and and we talked about this a lot on
the show like they're they're great at
at the bulk at the average case at
what's been sampled well they're
terrible when it comes to the corner
cases right and so for example when some
you know uh Alpha fold right was
heralded is the greatest thing that AI
has ever done we've solved the protein
folding problem because we get you know
93%
95% kind of accuracy on the structure
and everything here's the problem though
sometimes 99% is not enough right and
I'll give you an example you know the
James web telescope right this This
brilliant achievement NASA put this
awesome new telescope a million miles
from Earth okay it's bringing back all
this awesome data that mission is said
to have had
344 single points of failure if any one
of those 344 things failed the mission
right fails okay if you want to have
even even money like a 50% chance of
getting of getting the satellite up
there successfully of a mission success
every single one of those steps has to
have a three
n success rate
99.9% chance of success if you want a
99% chance that the mission succeeds
okay you need 13,000 chance of failure
at every single step this is not machine
learning folks like you know like gpt's
even been getting worse at basic
arithmetic lately like we we do have
this this expectation and a lot of
engineering domains of 100% accuracy or
5 NES of accuracy and we're just not
there yet with neural networks right
yeah could could I quickly touch on that
I mean um I don't think understanding in
a code base is even a binary because
again there's a non-stationary
environment which is to say the same
piece of code Run next week will behave
differently because you know the
situations change so in order to
completely understand a piece of code
you would also need to understand the
semantics of all of the libraries that
it's using and all of the libraries that
those libraries are using and so on and
it's just not possible so we have a kind
of reference frame and then we do
behavioral testing you know we do unit
tests and stuff like that but um I I
just think that it's it's it's something
that we delude ourselves that we have
when we actually don't have and then we
get into this modeling thing so now
we're talking about okay well let's
build a generative model and we always
have this question of do I understand
the domain enough to build such a model
and does it make sense to take a very
complicated system and to rify it into
because a model is a projection there is
no platonic model of anything
and how brittle would that model
be yeah I think I mean this is
um this is this is where we are with
with active inflence right so far um
people have
been pretty bad about um coming up with
great models right and it used to be
quite siloed like in speech processing
everybody uses hidden Market models and
in control theory everybody uses stage
space models and uh because it worked
for their um their fields and then deep
learning just threw everything off the
table
um active inference is at the stage
where okay now we we need to also come
up with the right generative models we
know they're going to be nested
models
um are they just going to be nested pom
DP kind of models or uh I personally
like actually the in the generative AI
fi these diffusion models right so so I
think yeah this is this is where we're
at at the moment so so what are the
right generative models because if you
have to come up with a very specialized
generative model for each application
uh they've just shifted the problem now
from algorithm design to generative
model design so so hopefully rather than
hopefully in engineering we can shift
from very specific algorithm design to
quite a generic generative model design
and then then we have gained a lot right
if we have generative models that work
across
modalities generative models where it
doesn't matter if the data is speech
data or Vision data or or some other
sensors right but as long as they're
nested and we have some kind of an
online pruning algorithm that takes out
notes that it doesn't need then then I
think then we have um you've made the
task for the engineer a lot a lot easier
because he doesn't have to come up with
a very specific solution for each
problem so this is having a library of
core knowledge basically yeah yeah
yeah well cool let me uh let me ask you
my uh kind of personal question so the
question I'm going to ask you and I'll
answer it first is if you remember when
you first became a basian so uh so for
me it was when I was uh struggling with
a an inference problem I was I was
collecting photons from from a
technology called two Photon microscopy
and and I had very few photons okay like
a sample would be like 30 or something
like that and I needed to measure the
Decay Lifetime and like I'm out there
reading papers how many photons you know
do I need in fact I find one that
literally said how many photons do you
need to measure Lifetime and they went
through a bunch of you know sort of
statistical analysis and the answer was
10,000 okay and I'm like I just don't
like I don't have 10,000 photons I have
you know 50 and I can see on a graph
what the lifetime is why the heck can't
statistics you know tell me what the
lifetime is and I'm sitting in my office
pondering this and I hear an office
manate of mine laughing he's just
chuckling and I go over and I'm like hey
man let what's going on what you
laughing at and he goes I'm just
laughing at this book and he's holding
this book called Data analysis of basian
tutorial bys civia right and he's
laughing at this example of a couchy
distribution where if you're trying to
estimate the peak and you're using the
mean you're never going to get the
answer because every sample that comes
in will just jump the mean you know all
around because the couchy distribution
has an infinite you know second moment
and yet there's this other procedure you
know maximum likelihood estimation using
using basian analysis and you get the
answer right and I'm like can I borrow
this book like I really need to see this
book yeah sure I take it I read my the
book it changes my life gives me a
totally different perspective you know
ever since then I've been a basian and
I've understood probability Theory like
much more deeply so I'm just curious if
there was a point in your career where
you shifted from being say Orthodox
statistician to to aasian if if you
remember when it was um
yeah and actually it's not very
different from from your path um the um
in 2003 a few books came out one was uh
Edwin James's book probability Theory
and the other David McKai book and um so
I I mean I bought I bought both books
because advin Janes I had heard of I
mean I I wasn't doing and stuff but this
was I mean it was also early internet
and I had heard that he was kind of uh
yeah he had a cult-like status in
probability Theory because he he would
post these papers on the internet that
would have a completely different view
on probability Theory yeah and so I
thought okay now I might as well just
buy the book and get all these papers
together and I I really loved that book
I never read it in full because it's
it's just too thick and too big but
everywhere you read in this book you you
learn something um the the clarity of
his mind is amazing and he is feisty and
he's personal and I liked that so much
that that it's it's it's almost like I
mean you you read the personality so I I
I loved that and then um in two so we
started looking for other beian books
and in in I think the book from cvia
that you talk about came out in 2006 or
something and so I bought that book and
I read the introdu uction and it really
no I read the prease and it really
struck a chord with me because in the
prease he
said yeah I mean I was a student and I
did the probability Theory and it was
all about dies and and and coin flips
and it was just it was was beautiful but
it was just toys and statistics that
worked on real problems but it couldn't
understand anything of it it just made
didn't make any sense arbitrary right
right arbitrary recipes and there is a
different solution you can solve
statistics just with probability Theory
and and and that he did in this book
it's a beautiful little book and I I I
still give it sometimes to students to
convince them of um of the beian method
because it's a short book the first five
chapters just read the first five
chapters and and you get a a different
view on statistical signal processing or
whatever actually or just on science so
um so I resonated what you say it was
also that little book by by uh
uh I by civia and later with John
skelling right and um yeah um yeah yeah
um and then the book that really I agree
with your book your book recommendations
by the way so Ed Edwin James's book
probability Theory the logic of of or uh
yeah probability Theory the logic of
science right isn't that it's called
so great it's so and it's so fun you're
right he's feisty and entertaining yeah
but the other book that really I mean
taught me machine learning Bas machine
learning was a Bishop's book I just saw
you oh pmo yeah and because he showed
that everything we do in machine
learning you can do better with with the
basian approach yeah and didn't he
Pioneer all of the um the the
variational message
passing right I the the L chapters of
his book about that MSR is working on
that I think it's it's still it's still
the book that I use for my machine
learning class I I love that book the uh
Chris Bishop's book I think it's still
one of the better books in in machine I
can't see it you said you saw
it
I yeah I can't my mind pattern
recognition there you go yeah prml look
at this yeah yeah pattern recognition
machine learning yeah well there we have
that's that's a good book list for our
listeners so we got you know pattern
recognition and machine learning by
Bishop right uh data analysis of basian
tutorial by DS civia and probability
Theory the logic of Science by Edwin
James awesome and the original you
mentioned earlier the I think it's a
1946 paper by Cox you know on on Cox's
theorem that's a really cool paper to
read if you can if you can get a copy of
it right right um but but but I should
also say I mean lately um I've been uh
there is this theoretical physicist
Ariel Kaa at Albany University and he's
doing amazing work if you're interested
in basian machine learning because he he
he he approaches physics really as an
inferential science as information
physics and uh so he has also a
monograph that you can just download
from his uh from his um from his website
and during Co he actually taught online
soers on YouTube you also have all the
it's it's fantastic it's it's really
fantastic
yeah beautiful listen I really have
appreciated you coming to talk with us
um I think you and Tim have been having
a lot of fun over there so again thank
you Bert for for coming to talk to us
it's been an absolute pleasure well
thank you the pleasure was totally mine
thanks thank you so much B